Republicans are celebrating two big
special election victories this morning
in Georgia karen handel won nearly 52
percent of the vote to defeat democrat
john Asaf that race was widely seen as a
referendum on the trump presidency and
it was the most expensive house race in
history president Trump congratulate
Handel yesterday in a tweet saying quote
fantastic job we're all very proud of
you and in South Carolina Republican
Ralph Norman won a race to replace
budget director Mick Mulvaney with those
victories Republicans have won all four
House special elections for place
appointees to the Trump administration
CBS News contributor ed O'Keefe is a
congressional reporter for The
Washington Post ed good morning good to
see you guys so what are the
implications of all this look these were
all Republican held seats and
Republicans won them so status quo has
been maintained but the fact that they
had to spend tens of millions of dollars
to defend them is a sign going into next
week also the Democrats been even more
in the judges yeah and and and and they
themselves I think you know we talked
about Republicans being in trouble with
an unpopular president I think Democrats
now really have to sit back and really
discuss how it is that they campaign in
the next year one thing they say is they
got run on something other than
anti-trump they try to present it
progressive message
I think it's fast you look at the
polling you guys put out yesterday when
people are asked are Democrats doing
enough or not enough to oppose the
president 32% say Democrats aren't doing
enough 32 percent say they're doing the
right amount
31% say they're doing too much so it's a
three-way split you look at among
Democrats there's a 44 or 45 split there
among not enough or right amount so the
Democrats still don't quite know what is
the correct cocktail if you will of
message that they need to be putting
together they're many I talked to late
last night that said we've got to come
up with our own agenda but then hit the
president as hard as we can also perhaps
didn't do enough of that and may have
compelled more people to turn out if he
had they just don't know at this point
indication of things to come in 2018
absolutely we're going to be up late
that night I think you know and if you
think about it tens of millions poured
into these special elections and
Republicans barely got by even in that
South Carolina race it was a
single-digit win for the Republican in a
place that it shouldn't have been
they're not going to have that much
money to defend
in dozens of competitive districts next
year could be a real scramble for
websites that's not I think Karen handle
one a little more comfortably than some
people thought and I mean how much of
this is is Republican voters saying
listen we're not necessarily that
concerned about the rush investigation
and we're not even concerned about the
inaction in Congress and the fact that
not much has happened and talking about
tax reform that we talked the health
care bill the health care bill has not
been finalized either yeah I mean and
that's that's important to remember here
this was a district that's been held for
40 years by Republicans there's more of
them there and for whatever reason they
felt compelled to turn out this time
they didn't turn out in the first round
perhaps because as you said they
understood we've got to support the
party demonstrate that we're with the
president and and do what we can to hold
the seat although health care bill from
the Republicans coming out in fashion by
a few people in secrecy right
does it have it really just one person
rich Mitch McConnell yeah does it have a
chance well look McConnell wouldn't be
setting the Senate on a glide path to
have a bill on the floor next week if he
didn't think it was going to pass all
he's going to need to do is find 50 of
his colleagues plus the Vice President
to pass it that's a messy way to do it
but passing a bill is passing a bill and
this this sort of disciplined focus of
keeping it secret until the last second
is something they've criticized for the
last eight years but works and a Senate
leader he knows that he can he can be
this focused disciplinary guy and and
and just pop it at the last second and
if there's enough in other people like
all this chatter about it being secret
won't matter when they realize that
there's things in there that sort of
leads on my next question because if the
secrecy seems to be ticking ticking a
lot of people off but that doesn't seem
as long as it gets the result that they
want you're saying that really die this
time next week they will be worried and
nobody knows the Senate like Mitch
McConnell exactly way to remember that
and it makes more people it when we
think it's going to make more people
happy the question is going to be costs
right and it not only costs but you know
do my premiums come down and how many
tens of millions of people would lose
their coverage the goal is to get lower
than 23 million Democrats will turn
around and say well you know even if a
few 15 60 and 70 million people were
losing their health care that's
unacceptable but the goal is to
basically produce a diet version of what
the house did so do Democrats have any
leverage
all they can do Gale is slow down the
train that's that's essentially all
Democrats are good for these days on
Capitol Hill especially in the Senate
there they can yell and scream and
produce Facebook live videos running
around the Capitol but that's about it
thank you good to see you guys